So together we've read the first half of
the Iliad and today I gave you an
assignment, right? So I have three
questions for you guys about Achilles.
The first one I
um the first question is
um imagine yourself
as Achilles.
How are you similar? What experience in
your life is very similar to that of
Achilles? And you said that
um
Achilles
is almost a mirror to you where uh you
love playing soccer but one day you felt
humiliated so you stopped playing soccer
and that tore at your heart. Okay. And
and your phrase was pride and
vulnerability.
And
that shows that by reading the Iliad, it
gives you tremendous insight into
yourself as as well as the nature of the
human heart where
um arrogance and insecurity are two
sides of the same coin, right? They're b
they're they're bundled together. Okay.
Um, another question is imagine Achilles
childhood and you said that Achilles
when he was young he was all he was
probably very rebellious, very
imaginative and that's that's true.
Okay, he's always testing boundaries.
Um, he has a very vivid imagination.
And then the last question is imagine
Achilles today. What would he be doing?
Okay. And here the answer is very
interesting. The answer is that he's pro
probably trying to be an Olympian
athlete. Okay. So the obvious answer
would be he's trying to be a soldier
because he loves war. But what you
recognize is that no. What Achilles
really wants to stand out and be admired
by everyone. He wants to be famous. And
so it makes more sense to be an Olympian
Olympian athlete uh than it does to be a
soldier. But you also recognize that uh
being an Olympian athlete has a lot of
restrictions because you need coaches,
you need sponsors, you need to follow a
certain um regiment and Achilles is a
very independent-minded person and so he
would rebel against all this authority,
all the structure, all this conformity
and so he probably fail in today's
society. Okay. So, um, the entire point
of this exercise is to show you that
what a great book does is excite your
imagination.
It helps your imagination
peer deeply into your own human heart
and see how complicated, how complex,
how dark it is. It also allows you to
imagine Achilles as a whole person. You
don't know him. You never you've never
met Achilles. And Achilles is honestly a
fictional character. He never existed,
but he's real to you. So that you're
able to imagine his past, his childhood,
and you're able to experience what he
experienced. What's even more powerful
is that you're able to imagine Achilles
into our world and see him as a living
and breathing human being.
So that's what a great book is. A great
book is composed of characters
that are real to you and make the world
more real to you. They excite your
imagination that allows you to think
much more deeply into yourself
as well as more imaginatively understand
the world around you. Okay. So now the
question then is how does this happen?
What are the mechanisms behind all this?
Okay, so
um there was a very famous American
literary cr uh critic named Harold
Bloom. He was at Yale. [clears throat]
He actually taught at Yale when I was
there. I studied English literature at
Yale and I actually sat in on a class of
his. Okay. But he is considered the most
famous American literary critic. And
here in his explanation for what a great
book is, what what is a great book?
[snorts and clears throat]
A great book is something that helps us
become human.
[clears throat]
So what he means by that is in a great
book the characters are different
because the characters are able to hear
themselves speak. Okay. hear yourself
speak.
Okay, those are his words. What does it
mean to hear yourself speak? It means
that as I'm speaking to you,
there's also a part of me that steps
back and analyzes what I say.
Okay? It has to make sense to me. It has
to make sense to you. And we call this
consciousness.
Okay. To be human means to be conscious.
But to be conscious is ultimately an act
of imagination
because while you're speaking, you have
to step back. Okay? We we actually call
this disassociation.
[clears throat]
You have to disassociate. Meaning
basically that as you are speaking, as
you are in this world, a part of you
almost like a ghost steps away and
observes the entire scene. And not only
am I imagining myself speaking, but I'm
also imagining what is happening inside
your mind, your heart as I'm speaking,
my effect on you. Okay? Right? So let's
look at how this applies to the Iliad.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. [clears throat] So remember the in
the first book of the Iliad manon
[clears throat]
and Achilles
they are having an argument.
They're having an argument because
Egamanon stole kidnapped a girl. The
father demanded a ransom demanded to
ransom her back. Eggmanon broke the
rules of war of piracy and said, "No, I
like her. Screw you. I'm the king of
kings. I'll do whatever I want." The
father is a priest of Apollo. Apollo um
starts a plague among the Greek
soldiers. They're all dying. And
Achilles says and says, "We're all
dying, okay, on the shores of Troy. So,
you have to give the girl back." And
Aman says, "Sure, I'll give her back,
but now I want your girl in return."
Okay. And it starts the main conflict of
the Iliad. What's interesting is that
how conscious they are. Okay.
So
what's happening is that this is a war
council
and in the war council the Greek
generals get together and decide on
policy
and so as Egenmanon is speaking
okay
if you observe his speech he's doing
three things at once Right. The first
and most important thing is that he's
responding to Achilles,
right? Achilles is says you have to give
the girl back and says fine, I'll give
the girl back, but in return I want your
girl. So that's that's a response to
Achilles. He feels as though Achilles
made him lose face. So now he wants to
make Achilles lose face as well. Okay.
But also what's important is that Eggman
is considering
how others are perceiving the
interaction. Right? Why does Eggmanon
require or demand Achilles girlfriend?
Because Agamenon does not want to lose
face amongst the others. Okay? So he
recognizes that if he just says to
Achilles, you know what, Achilles,
you're right.
He would lose face amongst the other
generals. He would lose respect. And in
this world, if [snorts] no one respects
you, you could get killed. Okay, these
people are gangsters. So he recognizes
that in order to save face, I must now
demand something from Achilles to show
that I am his superior. Okay, he's so
conscious of that as well. But also he's
he at the same time he's going to step
back okay [snorts]
and he's going to be conscious of his
own words to make sure that his words
together make sense that for him it is
coherent. Okay. And so what he says to
Achilles is why am I doing this? Because
I love my girlfriend. Okay. You stole
from me what I who I love and therefore
I must enact a vengeance on you. Okay.
So you see how coherent all this he is
saying to Achilles to ensure that you
understand that I'm your superior I'm
going to take what you most prize.
And then he's thinking about the
reaction of the works to make sure that
they understand that he's still the top
boss. But he's also in his head ensuring
that what he says is coherent in itself,
okay? That what he's doing has a
rationale. The rationale is because I
love her. Because you you're stealing
from me. My goodness love. I love her
more than my own wife. Kestra.
Okay. So you can see how coherent all
this and this is amazing if you think
about it right and this is what makes
Eggmanon a real character to us all
right but the other thing is that
Achilles behaves the same way okay he's
he is alive in the scene he is listening
to a manon and his response is this
why are you stealing from me what is
rightfully mine
manon I came to Troy not because I hate
the Trojans. I have nothing against the
Trojans. I came to Troy because you
ordered me to come to Troy. And so I'm
risking my life for you. You gain you
gain most of the treasure. You gain most
of a profit from this war. I take a
little bit and now you're stealing that
little bit from me as well. Okay. So why
is Achilles saying this? Achilles is
saying this as response to Agamelon, but
he's also saying this in order to win
sympathy from the others as well, right?
And he's also doing this because he's
conscious
of who he is. Okay? They're trying it's
a it's a battle of world views. Okay?
World view. [snorts] What they're really
trying to do is through their speeches,
they're trying to control reality. Okay?
through their speeches. They're trying
to impose the reality on others.
[snorts] And that's why this is such a
emotional
violent scene between the two. Okay.
And then what happens which is even more
amazing is that again Menon hears
Achilles speak and then what he does is
that he responds to Achilles
using his own memory.
and experience. Okay. And what he says
to Achilles is, "Achilles, you say that
you came here to fight for me. But we
all know that you are vain. You're a
narcissist. You're an You came
here to win glory for yourself. You're
just using me as an excuse, as a pretext
in order to win glory on the shores of
joy. That's why you really came. So
don't give me this crap about you making
all these sacrifices for me. You can't
make sacrifices for others because
you're a selfish Okay?
And then Achilles response is that fine.
If you do that, then I won't fight for
you anymore.
So you can see how real this is. Okay?
And again what's amazing is that this
all comes in the mind of one person
Homer the poet. [snorts]
Okay. So imagine this where as I'm
speaking to you, I'm able to mentally
lift off and absor and observe the
entire class where not only [snorts] am
I hearing myself speak, okay? And I'm
measuring and observing the effect of my
words, but I'm also able to go into your
mind one by one and think about how my
words are changing your reality. how
they're impacting your emotions, how
they're impacting your memory, and think
about their impact on you and how they
will guide your behavior and actions
tomorrow, 10 years from now. Okay? But
then what's even more amazing is that as
this is happening,
Neestor, right, Neestor,
who is the uh one of the older generals,
he comes into this scene and he tries to
reconcile Eggmanon and Achilles.
Okay. So, not only are the two main
characters have a life of their own, but
the observers have a life of their own
as well.
>> [snorts]
>> So in the Iliad, what's amazing is that
not only are the main characters alive,
but every single character, whether it's
Odysius,
Hector, Pryam, Neestor, they're all
alive as well with real emotions
and real feelings and real experiences.
Okay? And the reason why and we know
this is that we're if this is true then
we're able to look back at how this came
into being in the past
and we're also able to make predictions
about the future and all this is
coherent. Okay. So based on this, we
will now know that the major conflict in
the Iliad is the one between Egenon and
Achilles where they're struggling for
control over narrative
where Achilles wants everyone to believe
that he is doing everything he can to
save the Greeks. He's a hero. And Amen
is trying to get everyone to believe
that Achilles is just a selfish
Okay? And that's what leads them to
behave the way they do, including
suicidal behavior. Because remember, as
you read, Hector and the Trojans are
coming to burn down the ships of the
Greeks. Okay? They do that. Every single
Greek will be killed by the Trojans.
And even at this point in time,
both Agamenon and Achilles refuses to
give up their narrative.
Okay? They insist they're right.
So that when Odysius comes to Achilles
and begs Achilles, please come back and
join us. We'll give you all the money in
the world. Eggman has promised his
daughter to you.
We'll give you all of Troy after we
conquer Troy. And Achilles says, "No,
no, no, no. I want a man to come and
apologize. If he's not willing to come
and apologize to me, then screw all of
you."
Okay. So, you can see how human and how
real this is. And this is important for
us because now
we're able to step back and observe
ourselves
as well as others. We have greater
imagination. We have greater empathy. We
have greater curiosity.
Okay? And that's a power of a great
book. And this is how the Iliad created
the greatest greatest civilization on
earth in history, the Greek
civilization. Okay. All right. So any
questions be before I move on about
this?
Okay. Now what I want to discuss is
okay.
How did Homer do this? Because this is a
great mystery that has confused scholars
for centuries. We all know the Iliad is
one of the greatest books ever composed,
but we don't know who Homer is and we
don't know how he did this. There are
some who speculated that Homer were many
people. Okay. Um so there's confusion as
to who who Homer is. The Greeks
themselves call Homer the teacher and he
consider they consider him the father of
the civilization. So we know that Homer
was a was a real person but we know
almost nothing about him. Okay. So what
I'm going to do now is speculate as to
how he was able to do all this. Okay.
How was one human mind able to construct
entire universe with real people by
himself?
Okay.
All right.
So to understand this
um let's discuss how
identity how personality how
consciousness is created. Okay. So
basically what happens is that uh we
have experiences.
Okay. And these experiences become
short-term memory.
And then what happens is that our brains
will filter
these memories into emotions. Okay,
they're basically you will index your
experiences according to their emotional
strength or value. Okay, so happy,
sad, angry, whatever. Okay.
All right. So in other words, uh
something really important for you to
understand is that your memories
are your emotions.
Memories that create emotions in you
will come into you and help create your
identity. But em but memories that have
no emotions, you will never remember.
You'll just throw it out. Okay? And
[snorts and clears throat] then together
these memories will create your
identity.
Okay? And different combinations of
these memories will create different
identities. The reason why is that
different memories are indexed to
different locations. Okay? So your
identity in the in a school will be
different from your identity at home or
your identity when you go to America.
Okay? because you need different
identities to navigate the different
landscapes. Okay, does that make sense?
And together this will create your world
view. Your world view is just your
identity, who you are, how you perceive
the world, how you perceive yourself,
and this helps you make decisions. This
helps you navigate social relationships.
U and this determines how you behave.
Okay. Does does it does this make sense,
right? Okay. All right. So this is
basically the way that we understand how
our personality develops. But there are
sort of problems with this
understanding. Okay. The first major
problem with this is um the sorting
mechanism.
Okay. Basically, why do we respond to
different experiences
with different emotions? It doesn't make
sense. So, you can have the same
experience,
but you respond, but you can respond um
with different emotions. Okay? So, you
might get a 50 on a test. Some of you
will be really sad, but some of you be
like really happy like, "Wow, I thought
I thought I was going to get 10%." Now,
I got 50%. Okay? All right. Some of you
are like glass half empty. Some of you
are like glass half full.
So
that determines how we perceive the
world. But the question then is where
does this personality come from?
Okay.
Why are some people optimistic? Why are
some people pessimistic? And people are
born like that.
Now people and and your response could
be like well it's just genetic because
your both your parents are optimistic.
So you're optimistic. Both your parents
are pessimistic. Okay. Now you think
about your parents and ask yourself,
does your personality come from your
parents? And the answer is it doesn't.
Okay, the answer is that you're actually
different from your parents. I have
three kids. I know this cuz all three of
my kids are different from both my wife
and myself.
Okay. So the question is where does this
personality come from? That's the
question number one. We don't know the
answer. Question number two which is
more problematic is okay we know how
this process works but
where are the memories stored inside the
brain right we know how this works
psychologically but
you could but the question then is where
in the brain does this happen and the
answer is we don't know
we don't No, we know where in the brain
breathing happens. We know in the brain
where language acquisition happens, but
we don't know in the brain where
memories are formed and stored and
accessed. We don't know. That's really
weird, guys.
Okay. [snorts]
All right. So, that's that that's
problem number two. Storage of memories.
Okay.
Okay. And then question number three is
empathy.
Okay. Or theory of mind.
This is really theory, but it doesn't
really help us explain how empathy
works, right? It doesn't really help us
understand how we're able to perceive
the emotions of others. [snorts]
Now, you can say, well, it's because we
have these different identities and so
we just look at our own identity, but
that doesn't really help us understand
what's going on. Okay, so have these
three major problems created by modern
psychology. Okay, the first is where
does our personality come from? Because
our personality are our filter, right?
Our personality determines how we
perceive the world emotionally. Second
problem is
where does this all happen inside the
brain? We don't know. And the third
problem is empathy. Okay. How are we
able to perceive into the emotions of
others?
All right. Okay. And we don't know. So
I'm going to propose a theory to you
today. Okay. Which goes back to last
class.
Okay, imagine this. Imagine that we are
composed essentially of
um two selves. Okay,
two selves.
There is the body and the body comes
materially, right?
Okay, we know that. We know that through
evolution. But then our consciousness
comes from our interactions with the
universe. Okay, so our brain it's not a
storage facility. It's an antenna for
the vibrations of the universe. Okay?
And we call this consciousness.
And remember last class we discussed how
this consciousness, the universe is
conscious, right? And there are infinite
dimensions
to this consciousness. And this is where
our memories are stored. So a very
simple analogy is think about the
internet, right? You have a computer,
you have a laptop and some memory is
stored on the laptop but most of it is
actually stored in the cloud and how the
computer works is by interacting with
the internet your computer becomes more
conscious. Okay, does that make sense?
Same thing here where if you just use
the human brain and just assume that
everything comes from the human brain,
nothing makes sense. But if you assume
that the human brain is merely an
antenna to the universal consciousness,
it makes a lot more sense. Okay. And how
and not only that, but by imagination,
by consciousness, we're able to implant
ourselves into
the universe. Okay? And different
emotions
uh implant themselves in different
wavelengths, different dimensions. Okay?
Does that make sense? So the combination
of your emotions now lead to a unique
imprint in the universe.
Okay?
And different personalities will
obviously have the same imprint in the
universe. And we call this archetypes.
Archetypes. This is um from Carl Young
who is a
Swiss psychologist. Okay. Carl Young.
The word he uses archetypes.
They're different personalities and they
are accessing the same parts of the
universe and so they behave the same.
That's why certain people look alike.
Okay. If you're an evil person, you look
you have a certain look to your face,
right? If you're a good person, you have
a certain look to your face. Okay? If
you're clever, you have a certain look.
Okay? So, archetypes. And so, what's
happening is that what Homer is doing is
that he's opened his mind to the
universe and therefore he's able to
access all archetypes. Okay? We all do
this for empathy, but Homer's able to do
this at a greater level than everyone
else. Okay?
[snorts] And then he's able to
transplant these archetypes into the
world of the Iliad. And that's how he's
able to create what he does. A word we
have for these people are prophets,
right? What are prophets? Prophets are
those who bring the truth.
>> [snorts]
>> of the universe onto our world and
construct it in a language that allows
us to access this truth eternally. Okay.
So in this time in history poets are
prophets are teachers.
These are the same
function. Okay. where where where you're
accessing the truth of the universe and
you're spreading this truth through
words that enable the construction of
civilization.
Okay.
So im and we think this is true. Why?
Because think about what's how amazing
it is that the Iliad was written 2500
years ago. Okay? It was written 2500
years ago by this guy Homer living in
the Mediterranean, the Aian,
right? Different culture, different
time, but the Iliad is able to speak
directly to you as a Chinese person
living in China in the 21st century. Not
only that, but you're able to imagine
Achilles as yourself.
So if we assume that the universe is
conscious and it is infinite and eternal
and there are archetypes that exist
within this universe that Homer is able
to draw on then that makes sense now.
Okay, this is both spaceless and
timeless. This consciousness,
right? Is this clear you guys?
Okay?
Because then because if if this is not
true, then you have to ask answer the
question, how was Homer able to do this?
Right? How was able to construct
characters like Achilles, Odysius, Amen
that are so real that they feel alive to
us? That they're so real that we can
hear them speak to themselves. so real
that they themselves can hear themselves
speak to others.
Okay.
Any questions?
Ask a question. Make sure you you
understand this theory. Okay. This is
actually a very complex theory.
Um yeah,
sorry.
>> Yeah, just just speak.
>> Mhm. Um the quote unquote prophets. So
in this series is actually not a
technically not a prophet because they
are not predicting future, right?
Because universe is spaceless or or
timeless. So that they are actually
talking about the truth, right? Right?
So they are not making predictions
because all of them are already written
down in the universe. Okay.
Okay.
So um the word prophet doesn't actually
mean someone who who predicts the
future. Okay. The pro the word prophet
actually means someone who speaks the
truth.
Speaks truth.
Okay. Because throughout most of you of
human history, when you say someone's a
prophet and he speaks truth, what you're
really saying is that he's speaking the
word of God, right? Because what is
truth? Truth is the universe,
which is God.
So when you speak truth, you're speaking
the universe. And what is the universe?
The universe is past, present, and
future all together. It is beyond space
and beyond time.
So when you speak the truth, the truth
is what has happened, what is happening
now, and what will happen in the future.
Okay? So the the way that you test his
words is see if it happens.
Right? And a lot of this truth is this
moral truth where
if you do evil onto others, evil will
come onto you. Okay? So like so the
story of Achilles, right? where Achilles
he's stuck in the situation where
he wants a man to apologize so that he
can go fight the Trojans.
A man refuses to apologize.
So Achilles, what does he do? Well, he
sacrifices Petroles, right? It's a death
of Petroles that enables Achilles to go
fight the Trojans. So he's done evil
onto Petetro. And because he's done
that, evil will not come on to Achilles.
Okay.
So yeah, you so we think prophets means
speaking the future, but it's really
speaking the truth. Okay. Because truth
is eternal. If you do evil onto others,
then evil will have to come on to you.
So it's both a prediction as well as a
moral judgment.
Okay? Does that make sense? And so the
prophet, the poet, the teacher again
same same idea where why why is the
person a poet? Because how do you know
it's truth? You know it's truth because
it's beautiful. Because it speaks to
you. Okay? Do you understand? So when
Homer is going around because this this
is an illiterate culture, right? No,
there's no writing going on. So what
he's doing is he's going to different
places, he's telling the story of the
Iliad. He's speaking and as he's
speaking it's like music to the
listeners. It's beautiful. It's poetry
but it's beautiful because it's also
truthful. Okay. Because they feel as
though Achilles is a real person with
real emotions
and then Achilles comes and um helps
them better understand themselves. Okay.
So that's poet. The teacher is like okay
how do you understand yourself? You
understand yourself by understanding the
Iliad. Okay, by understanding the
psychology,
the motivations, the emotions of these
individuals, you can better understand
yourself. And once you do that, once
you're able to hear yourself speak, once
you're able to have more consciousness,
then that gives birth to civilization.
Okay? because not only are you able to
imagine but you're able to imagine with
other people as well. So if so if you
look at Greek culture uh whether it's
Plato whether it's facilities whether
it's iselist okay this is the greatest
thinkers greatest intellectuals of Greek
civilization they're all derivative of
Homer okay they're all operating within
Homer's universe and working off that
universe okay but their applications are
different so for example ficidities what
he does is that he writes in a very
homer way in that um his characters are
always giving speeches. The difference
of course is that Fusidities is writing
about real people, real events whereas
Homer, he's just writing about people.
He's not right. He's singing about
people of his imagination that um are
part of the Greek cultural uh landscape.
Okay. Does that make sense?
Okay.
Okay. All right. So in literature,
prediction and truth are the same thing,
right? If you're going to speak truth,
you can predict the future,
right? [snorts] Because that's what
truth is. Truth is eternal. Past,
present, and future collide together.
They converge [clears throat] on truth.
All right. Any more questions?
Okay.
Okay. So, um, we have we have up to book
16 for Friday. Okay.